[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro pas
pour cette équité à l'issue du premier
tour avec quelques certitudes et
beaucoup de questions et on se retrouve
à l'issue de deuxième tour avant les
législatives avec encore quelques
certitudes mais encore plus de questions
et pour y répondre jean baptiste du
clermont ce jour bonjour latine vient
sûrement je vous attends c'est le maître
de conférences à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin pts spéciste de
droit constitutionnel
florence mercadé vous êtes avocat au
barreau de versailles vient st patrice
stéphane rousseau ancien doyen de la
faculté de droit vers ses cinq enfants
et toujours bien sûr enseignants bien
sûr droit public
bonjour patrice pour ce fou et jean
charles lajoie dix éditeurs bonjour
alors voilà on dit qu un peu plus de
certitude puisque maintenant on attend
du président de la république est ce que
c'est la seule certitude d'ailleurs
qu'on est pour l'instant parce qu'on
attend évidemment le gouvernement
n'attend législatives mais ou alors pour
poser la question autrement comment
comment vous analyser les raisons de la
victoire ce que c'est la jeunesse du
candidat ce que c'est le renouvellement
de l'offre politique c'est le désir de
changement
tout ce qu'on dit depuis deux ans c'est
à dire que même un âne serait élu face à
marine le pen
non mais c'est quand même le premier
truc c'est la première fois qu'on traite
le nouveau président
j'aime beaucoup de nouveaux présidents
donc c'est pas du tout n'est guère c'est
que voilà on va regarder faire et
j'espère j'espère qu'il aura de la
majorité une majorité pour pour diriger
le sait les lilas n'arrive au dossier
que je souhaite mais voilà rien on avait
toujours dit toute personne qui arrivera
au deuxième tour car l'udc arrive
dans cette bulle c'était une teinte et
au rêve donc voilà je trouve qu a pas
tellement de surprises en milliards de
raisons il ya peut-être plus de raisons
que ça à l'élection enfin il ya en effet
le fait que la candidate en face était
la candidate du front national mais il
ya quand même au delà de ça je pense
c'est pas un désir de renouvellement
une offre politique nouvelle non mais ça
ça justifie son élection au premier tour
cette volonté d'avoir une offre nouvelle
quelqu'un de plus jeune et de dire non
que ce soit monsieur fillon monsieur
amour monsieur mélenchon donc c'est
peut-être au niveau du premier tour que
ça s'est décidé sur ce sur ce créneau là
et sur ce choix là après effectivement
deuxième tour il y avait une certitude
c'est qu'il serait élu l'incertitude
c'était le chantage le score qui est un
bon sens qui est un score alors est-ce
qu'il est bien élu mais l'élu il est
quand même bien aimé avec un taux
d'abstentionnistes vote blanc
exceptionnelle en temps
mais mais il est quand même bien élu il
ya eu un faux débat mon point de vue qui
consiste à dire ben voilà il est présent
au second tour et donc je ne me sens pas
du tout concerné c'est pas du tout mon
programme donc j'ai m'abstenir où j'ai
voté blanc
mais on est quand même dans la logique
d'un scrutin à deux tours il vous
connaissez le refrain pas triste mais au
premier tour on choisit et au second
tour en ayant l île
voilà donc il s'agissait il a d'ailleurs
dit m'avait d'ailleurs vie donc je
m'étonne que l'on se soit sensible à ce
genre d'arguments d'autant que si on
prend les chiffres à la parole aux
français quoi il est élu avec 43%
je crois des suffrages quel celui qui
était le mieux au long de cette et 39 et
sarkozy 40 qui ne s'aiment pas c'est pas
négligeable quand même on s'est quand
même face à le pen
pas tout à fait pareil sinon mais si on
compare à temps on peut comparer les
chirac a été très bien négocié non mais
surtout un chiffre qui veut pas dire
grand chose mais ça au coach je suis
ravi que soient élus mais se dire qu'il
a été mieux et luc sarkoland
voilà c'est de l'opposant jeunes et ce
n'est pas le même genre de chien avant
les élections chirac
on peut faire parler les chiffres en
comparant avec l'édition de 2002 dans
l'apparat jean-marie open où on avait 28
% d'abstention au premier tour et
l'abstention a reculé de 8 points au
second alors que la celle inverse c'est
à dire que finalement il ya eu moins
moins de mobilisation pour finalement
contesté donc
marine le pen et il ya eu donc c'est je
crois 23 21 % d'abstention s'est passé
fin c'est augmenté de 3 points donc ça
c'est assez impressionnant et puis aussi
le vous avez raison mobilisés à
mobilisation très forte et il ya aussi
le fait que jean marie le pen avait pu
obtenir qu'un seul point
donc en 2002 et que là cette fois à
marine le pen
même si vous êtes encore au 2e tour où
exactement alors que là on attendait
marine le pen donc première mais enfin
il faut quand même souligner que faire
avec un score très honorable et là on
peut quand même c'est la différence
allait je crois de 12 5 points entre les
deux tours ce qui est quand même assez
impressionnant et qui fait 2 du front
national on voit en plus face qu'est ce
qui est énorme et c'est là en effet la
première fois que le front national
bénéficier d'une réserve de voix à
l'issue du premier tour et en cela ses
notables
non alors même si elle venait de chez
fillon un peu de chez dupont aignan en
tête de chat mélenchon ça serait parti à
50 50 enfin 50% des gens qui avaient
voté le pen et 50 % ont voté macro mais
c'est vrai il y avait des iv une réserve
un petit réserves à droite alors qu'en
2002 en effet c'était les mêmes scores
restent est saturée dès le premier tour
qu'est ce qui est très étonnant ci
reprend la situation jusqu'au point 2002
de chirac et de et de macron sait on a
beaucoup reproché à jacques chirac élu à
plus de 80% des voix de ne pas avoir
prise en compte justement le fait qu'il
avait été élu avec d'autres voies que
celles des partisans du rpr à l'époque
enfin ou de l'ump et donc n'a pas tenu
compte alors que toute la théorie de
macron c'est justement d'essayer de 10
on va essayer de rassembler à droite à
gauche des gens qui ne n'ont pas
forcément les bonnes opinions
donc non trépanier c'est déjà dans son
adn politique de rassemblement
chirac il est dans sa proposition même
pas de ce point de vue là on n'est pas
étonné de ce
réaction mais il faut pas non plus bon
43 des inscrits finalement c'est un
score assez habituel c'est bondi après
au second tour bon on a un président qui
est lui est finalement il ya des vols
qui sont reportés sur lui et qui ne sont
pas forcément des votes d'adhésion mais
c'est un grand classique un mitterrand
en 81 avaient pu bénéficier des voix
parce que c'était un vote qui avait été
exprimée aussi contre valéry giscard
d'estaing également françois hollande
c'est un vote qui avait été exprimée
aussi pour partie contre nicolas sarkozy
donc on dit beaucoup que l'élection
finalement ne ressemble pas à la france
mais bon le second tour est aussi un
choix qu'il faut faire sur deux
candidats restants ça ce que disait
stéphane en éliminer c'est pas ces
passerelles nouveau cocon qu'on élimine
alors on élimine avec plus ou moins de
force et plus ou moins de volonté
d'éliminer mais mes bébés on élimine à
chaque fois nous connaissait évidemment
le philosophe bon vous embrasse ils
deviennent intervenants le point qui est
assez passionnant et 10 des français ont
choisi macro pour se renouveler
eux-mêmes illettrés extrêmement fin et
gagne jéhovah plus en plus profondément
il dit cette élection pourrait être une
réponse inconsciente à l'expulsion des
protestants par louis xiv qui a fermé la
voie de la réforme en france vous avez
trois jours c'est vrai que c'est vrai
qu' on est devenu un pays économiquement
catholique et il ya trois ans et demi au
libéralisme c'est le ca a été le ct le
le communisme
le fascisme et le catholicisme c'est aux
que vous dites c'est vrai que là on voit
devient peut-être un pays protestant
il est exact que c'est un éclairage
intéressant que cela n'apparaissait pas
clairement dans le débat commentant
céder petit truc qui m'échappe de temps
en temps ça doit l'être mais non taxés
mais c'est tout à fait non parce que
alors au delà puisque c'est en même
temps à président qui est plutôt pro
européen qui va tenir s'entendre
probablement avec angela merkel avec
d'autres dirigeants européens
est-ce que c'est pas une élection qui
remet la france au sein de l'europe
alors que on a eu quand même au premier
tour 10 candidats qui étaient plutôt
anti européen contre on a expliqué c'est
vrai nous comprend votre triste nous
bien construit non c'est vrai qu'on ne
voulait pas parler de louis xiv
nous ne parlons pas de la révocation de
l'édit de nantes ont évidemment un lien
essentiel mâcon on a un peu l'impression
pour une fois le président donc emmanuel
macron valais va se rendre en allemagne
non pas pour quémander mais vous
proposez faire que c'est très souvent
l'impression que tous les présidents les
derniers prison qui allait en allemagne
c'est pour dire est-ce qu'on pourrait
réduire un peu les exigences de l'europe
et ce qu'il faut lâcher un peu de lest
et ses terres il y avait un côté un peu
presque mendiants et là on a
l'impression qu'il va y aller en disant
bon bah et qu'est ce qu'on fait on
démarre on va rien pulsé le de l'énergie
on n'est pas
j'ai été bien élu sur un programme
européen j'étais quasiment le seul des
onze candidats est aussi gros européen
donc voilà il ya un enthousiasme
sûrement qui sera bien accueillie par
les autres chefs d'état est très bon les
gens nous de lundi la une était vraiment
dithyrambique que ce soit en allemagne
même même en angleterre donc et dans le
monde entier
c'est vrai qu'il ya quelque chose qui
s'est passée action au delà de nos
frontières
est ce qu'on pensait qu'il ya quelque
chose qui s'est passé ou qui est en
train de se passer en france une
majorité une majorité les républicains
oui dans le cadre d'une cohabitation bon
a passé un peu quelque chose mais pas
trop en revanche si si la république en
marche parvient à avoir une majorité
afin même relative
là on pourra dire qu'il se passe quelque
chose mais vous n'avez pas l'impression
quand même mais mal à s'ouvrir
électorale pour sa marque rappelle quand
même que les gens de la droite classique
et de la gauche classique avait pris un
petit coup de leur intervention s'était
même des gens jeunes comme eux comme
baroin
c'est pas une question d'état civil les
jeunes paraissent impressionnants c'est
la récuser dans du pouvoir le discours
épine bien on a l'impression que là ils
sont tous en train de ramer pour essayer
de rattraper le train en marche en a
mais on va présenter vite un programme
qui va être séduisant etc
mais avec toujours ce vocabulaire qui
commence presque adapté n'en suis pas il
ya une cave lunaire jeu utilise des
formats kron et ses acolytes qu'il
peut-être plus séduisant plus plus
moderne plus nouveau on a l'impression
qu'il se passe quelque chose depuis là
il a quand même réussi à dynamiter fois
la totalité des partis politiques
exigent tout en allongeant on parlera
peut-être après de ce qui peut se passer
au cours des élections de la formation
du gouvernement et aidera mais justement
la droite la gauche on voit bien que les
deux sont au au bord de l'implosion
l'explosion nationale et en parlera du
front national il ya une toute petite
différence c'est que les républicains
ils vont peut-être imploser un petit peu
moins vite que le ps qu'ils avaient
quand même faire un score beaucoup plus
important c'est quand même à près de 20
% donc c'est quand même un socle assez
important alors que c'est vrai que le ps
à 6%
versez ça laisse des traces difficiles
ça va être ça va être plus compliqué et
puis là au ps ils sont tous déjà en
train de dire on va faire un mouvement
un autre parti un autre tout le monde
part dans tous les sens en clair public
et j'essayais peut tenir de tenir la
baraque
donc ça a peut-être résisté plus
longtemps mais c'est vrai que macro est
le véritable ans réussit un dynamitage
extraordinaire déjà les républicains sur
le programme qu'ils ont plus ou moins
annoncée aujourd'hui est tellement
adoucie et l'état et dans tout ce qui
été radié fait ressortir la balle aux
mille fonctionnaires et bien ouf voilà
parce que j'espère que mon cher jean
baptiste que nous sommes sensés de la
lame on n'a pas les noms nous attendons
la visite était prêt sur l'offre de
services tv fait voilà je dois b c'est
impressionnant de voir à quel point des
primaires sont organisées le temps long
et fait sur des personnes des noms des
programmes et puis là en l'espace de
quelques temps un tripatouillage sur les
programmes épilogue le programme du ps
et les républicains a changé et on part
sur une nouvelle tonnes c'est quand même
assez impressionnant de démocratie si
cette légende ne laisse que cette passe
à la pièce ça oui c'est ça et là tout h
et non en même temps on peut
difficilement reprocher au ps
d'abandonner le programme d'amont parce
que sinon comme les et très justement
cambadélis si on garde la même on va
faire ce qui pourrait peut-être de la
vieille politique mais c'est comme ça
paraît assez athlétique
voilà ce qu'ils étaient ce qui
paraissait idiot probablement c'est
d'avoir pris programme d'amont avant
mais en tout cas ne pas le garder ça me
parait il
soutenus les uns et les autres des
candidats avec lesquels ils n'étaient
pas d'accord quand même c'est comme si
l'humanité sont les primaires ps que
d'une certaine façon lors d'une élection
d'emmanuel macron ne ne met pas aux
joues à jour au fond les recompositions
qui était latente pas dans l'oeuvre dans
la vie politique c'est à dire quoi on
sait très bien que la gauche s'était
divisé on l'a vu pendant tout le
quinquennat de françois hollande
et on sait très bien que la droite on le
voit avec des gens comme vous qui y est
où des gens comme m haies est divisée
entre une tendance plutôt droit thiel
tendance eux plutôt plutôt centriste
est-ce que voilà ce que c'est cette
élection là ne de n'accélère pas cette
recomposition
il ya cette dualité dont vous parlez et
puis il y en a une autre city qui est
quand même très structurante dans la vie
politique française depuis depuis
peut-être une douzaine quinzaine
d'années c'est pour résumer les choses
ceux qui voient la vie enfin qui voit la
france boucle et renfermée sur elle même
et puis ce qui qui disent il ya la
mondialisation alors on peut être contre
mais on peut être aussi contre le contre
le mauvais temps contre la faim dans le
monde et pour les uns et à faire la
tendance voilà prenons le train en
marche si j'ose dire
et donc cette dualité à la part est
vraiment là au regard des deux candidats
qui étaient présents second tour au
regard des débats qui s'instaure et au
regard de la recomposition à laquelle on
assiste
vous avez les partisans de la fermeture
et puis ceux qui sont plutôt partisan
d'ouverture aussi et sur la
recomposition l'accélération de la
recomposition mois ci
ravi que ça véritablement parce que
c'est ça pousse un certain optimisme on
ne peut voir sac avec des yeux doux
façon très agréable on se dit que la
france veut un peu aller dans le bon
sens qu'on va arrêter d'un pessimisme
terrils on a peut-être arrêter d'être
plus malheureux que les habitants de
kaboul enfin je veux dire ian williams
team petit truc croise d'erreur ses
prévisions voilà on verra s'ils se
plantent que ce que personne ne devrait
souhaiter en tout cas moi je ne souhaite
pas mais found in peace il pourrait
avoir toutes les cartes en mains s'ils
s'y fait pas de boulette ou school
législatif si voilà on va voir comment
se comportent ces candidats etc
mais enfin franchement laid comme on dit
souvent tous les clignotants sont au
vert pour que les clignotants même les
clignotants économiques sont au vert les
gifles ce matin sont plutôt bons
commerce extérieur
les industriels certes mais il a de la
chance ça arrive au moment où ça s'est
bien passé grâce à l'année et demie où
elle était ministre
[Rires]
je voulais vous d'un peu de peter super
déçu parce qu'il dit chose qui était qui
assez intéressante je trouve sur
l'évolution économique
au fond comme le but de figaro chez hbo
marché on ne s'est longtemps donné que
la peine de naître au bon endroit et
c'est à dire que c'est vrai que si nous
y étiez au 19e siècle français ou
anglais les plus de chance de bien vivre
qui si vous y étiez
je ne sais pas un bien bon c'est ça qui
a changé aussi dans le monde annonce
même si on est encore dedans c'est
encore quand même des endroits pas
tellement d'accord un coup de fil aux
abandons mais vous ne voudriez pas la
puissance de ce raisonnement est vexé
c'est la mondialisation c'est la
mondialisation c'est en effet la peur
pour un certain nombre de gens qui ont
qui sont nés au bon endroit de perdre
des avantages qu'ils ont et qu'ils
avaient jusqu'à présent parce qu'il ya
la concurrence parce qu'il ya d'autres
gens guéri par coproduit ailleurs parce
qu'on voit là c'est quand même ça non
vous êtes d'accord avec moi maintenant
alors c'est à dire pas d'accord et à
cinq secondes
non mais c'est bien mais quand j'écris
je traduis sauter des bombes et les
peurs aujourd'hui sont les mêmes des
peurs aujourd'hui sont les mêmes que
celles que vous décrivez c'est ça oui
comment les mains jamais autre s'est
plaint ce problème de traduction dans le
crash
hélas les années dans le texte mais huit
mandats bonne ampleur c'est non mais
c'est ça moi je vais lui acheter ma
nomination je suis peut-être n'ont pas
tardé parce que je veux dire
allez vous voyez bien que la peur de la
mondialisation il vient du fait que l'on
produit aujourd'hui des choses qu'on ne
produisait pas dire que ces produits
arrivent ici alors qu'il n'arrivait pas
autrefois et que au fond m un endroit à
un autre du monde aujourd'hui est moins
important que les tels que le relevé que
la montée des populismes des
nationalismes vient du fait que des gens
ont peur de perdre le peu qu'ils
possèdent encore parce que ça vient ça
vient d'ailleurs et c'est s'est produit
moins cher et voilà mais cela étant sur
la première partie de votre raisonnement
de marie n'en demeure pas moins qui vaut
peut-être mieux vivre et même en france
puis tout vivre au soudan de la chine de
la 5e' c'est ça mais les vrais
concurrents aujourd'hui non enfin certes
certes oui c'est sûr de leur ego mis la
droite donc on était sur la droite
pardon parce que c'est un peu décousu
parlant de la gauche parce que l' avis
on arrive alors elle à gauche quel parti
socialiste qui a refait ont vite fait
bien fait un programme législatives et
puis des boues mot qui laisse ça et là
loria benoît hamon qui crée son
mouvement
d'immenses pompes avery
bienvenue d'al-baïda l'angoissé
reconstitution de ligue dissoute c'est
terrible face le terrain ça veut dire
quoi encore c'est très difficile on se
projette déjà dans l'après législatives
bref c'est ça l'idée de créer ces
mouvements c'est ce dont j'ai pas
compris que ces mouvements avaient été
constituées justement pour donner une
dynamique aux élections législatives de
juin ça tue le mouvement tu vas le
mouvement entre guillemets du ps pour
les législatives parce que si déjà ils
disent dans mais de façon nous on va
créer nos mouvements à côté que
résultats des partis tels que tel que ça
a été présenté ce matin par par benoît
hamon sur france inter s'est fait comme
ça ressemble fortement à un mouvement
qui va devenir un parti enfin c'est
comme ça que moi je l'ait compris dans
dans ses explications
donc sauf que c'est un pays se tire une
balle dans le pied pour les législatives
quand il fondé de tels mouvements en
parallèle et c'est comme ça que j'ai une
certaine expertise a l'impression que
c'est un peu 3 pétroleuses ont plutôt la
presse qu'une intention de tirer sur ce
qui reste du ps ni que de se tirer une
balle dans le pied voilà je pensais
plutôt 3 exécute risque
3 c'est que trois filles qui vont se
tirer une balle après tout sans refaire
l'histoire dans les années soixante dix
les clubs qui existent et ont permis à
la la la création et la rénovation du
oui mais dans tous ses clubs y avait
quand même des penseurs et des gens qui
pensaient vraiment dont alors y avait
donc qui est parvenu à fédérer des
antagonismes désolât ben oui on avait
l'impression que c'était quand même des
gens qui réfléchissent et on pouvait ne
pas partager leurs idées mais il y avait
de la réflexion il en a déçu plus simple
si vous aviez de 5ème république qui
était à l'apogée de dassault systèmes si
vous avez d'un côté la droite
et puis vous pourriez penser
raisonnablement que vous voudrez certain
nombre de temps
même si perfide disait si nous ne
faisons pas de bêtises on ne sont au
pouvoir pendant 30 ans la haye la gauche
pouvait récompense est arrivée au
pouvoir un moment non oui alors que là
c'est plus compliqué mais c'est tout le
monde c'était un peu con plus dans leurs
biens une alternance presque automatique
non mais j'ai surtout l'impression que
c'est autant ces clubs là c'était pour
avoir une réflexion pour sortir à
quelque chose de commun est de
construire la gauche là ces mouvements
là j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont un peu
chacun dans leur coin photo voilà
jardinage noter chacun dans leur coin et
pas essayer de réfléchir ensemble pour
faire quelque chose enfin c'est d'autant
que mario telo tellement ironique
ces deux mouvements pense donc leur
idéologie sur un élargissement au parti
socialiste et à l'idée d'un mouvement
trans partisan c'est à dire réellement à
au projet qu'amener emmanuel macron
absolument c'est totalement ironique
c'est de regarder c'est plutôt du côté
de la gauche
bah justement on sait pas trop quel
conseil c'est un peu le problème pour
tous les partis en ce moment alors et
manuel valls a auto ça parce que le
pauvre il a il a très très mal joué
enfin je trouve ça quand même assez
exsangue il s'est prononcé pour
l'allonger envie tout ce qui est quand
même assez courageux très bien il
voulait pas téléphoné à emmanuel macron
a pour lui dire voilà j'aimerai bien
concourir sous la bannière en marche au
niveau des législatives il dit rien il
adhère pas au mouvement puisque pour
pouvoir déposer et candidater pour être
député il faut être à minima adhérents
du mouvement
donc ils adhèrent pas au mouvement et il
vient déclarer sans prévenir emmanuel
macron ni personne qui voudrait
concourir sous les bannières dans marche
je trouve que c'est un peu cavalier est
très très mal ficelé diplomatiquement
complètement à côté de la plaque donc
derrière lui dix mais vous n'avez pas
adhérer
vous vous réveillez deux jours après les
élections et la veille de la clôture
puisque il s'est réveillé hier et c'est
ce soir que les dossiers sont finies et
alors non mais c'est pas on n'est pas
dans l'arche de noé à en marche bien il
faut comprendre je pense qu'il ya c'est
ne pas comprendre le mouvement que de
dix robes il était premier ministre on
aurait pu prendre une ambiance assez la
vieille politique là nous avons eu
l'idée d époque je me sers des
réformateurs de jean-jacques
servan-schreiber et jean lecanuet où
selon les circonscriptions il présentait
des candidats ou pas par exemple y avait
du monde où le maire de grenoble avait
voilà bat contre lequel ne présentait
pas de candidat puis y avait des
candidats de droite et qui était assez
ouverte contre lesquels ne présentait
pas de candidat
ça peut sembler pas dans la même mais on
n'est pas du tout faire n'est pas du
tout dans la semaine là on part on a
zéro députés donc on n'est pas en train
de dire je vais faire trucs moins dans
lé là on n'a pas de député donc l'idée
c'est d'essayer d'avoir des candidats
pour présenter des gens si vous avez
quelqu'un comme manuel valle apprécié
mais moi j'ai voté pour lui au premier
tour et voter pour lui au deuxième tour
je soutiens cette politique au fond on
pense la même chose
on a été conquérant un moment donné et
c'est pour ça que c'est mal mais il avec
elle expliqué avant et puis adhérer non
mais ça serait passé différents genres
tellement aberrant c'est qu'il n'y ait
pas de téléphoner à mal bien 6 5 est
incompréhensible
il y avait bien main griveaux qui était
sur un sur europe 1 au moment où valsent
la nouvelle gamme est révolue
c'est quand même une des personnes qui
est la plus proche d'eux
emmanuel macron dont je pense que ils
gagnent bien placé pour savoir si s'est
passé quelque chose ou pas il tombe est
il tombé de l'armoire sur europe 1 en
disant bas je ne sais pas où on découvre
cependant avoir maintenant europe 1 ça
ne fait pas du bon marché en face une
occasion que qui est saisie d'ailleurs
une grand messe de faire valoir comme
vous le dites florence que c'est une
ancienne manière de faire bioéthique
vous prenez la file comme tout le monde
premier ancien premier ministre parce
que je l'aï la donner il a donné au
mouvement en marche une occasion de
faire valoir de faire valoir la façon
qu'ils mèneront en marche fait de la
politique
j'ai fait ma de la politique comme les
autres partis et je trouve ça pas
personnellement très bien oui
non mais il aurait fait entre nous c'est
tout simplement dommage qu'il n'ai pas
téléphoné macro effectivement en temps
quand un ancien premier ministre
je pense que macroule aurait pris au
téléphone quitte à lui dit a coûté sympa
mais je ne veux plus jamais entendre
parler de toi ce que tu sais qu'on sera
pas prêt politiquement mais au moins ils
seraient ils se seraient parlé et je
pense que c'est ridicule
et si valls avait une fin de non
recevoir de la part du président et je
serai il se serait tuée puis ça aurait
été aussi bien il aurait pu avoir un
autre projet mais là c'est très curieux
patte de d'arrivée sa soeur et sa course
est de voir avec le fait d'un mouvement
qui veut regrouper des gens de droite et
s'il avait fait les choses dans les
règles et selon la nouvelle mais à la
façon de faire de la politique dans
marche
peut-être qu'il n'aurait pas pris la
porte dans la chine au rhume enfin
flambé non plus que digne à une façon de
faire de la politique nouvelle
je suis la maman c'est une façon de
faire de la politique qui pourrait vite
être humiliante si vous demandez un
ancien premier ministre que manuel valls
a mais ton cv en ligne
une gamine audités demandé c'était de
passer un coup de téléphone mais non
téléphone lui reprocher parce que notre
téléphone est ce que le coup est ce que
c'est une vraie ville sans carte après
téléphone ça d'un hors jeu décisif mais
c'est au moins d'adhérer c'est minimum
mais méfiez-vous florence parce qu'il
faudrait pas que cette nouvelle façon de
faire de la politique ça devienne
tellement caricaturale que dans quinze
jours on va trop s'en moque et on va
dire années ont déjà versé clients
kharijites à déposer mon cv ce que je
peux vous une question j'ai qua non
quand même revenir au fond ce que dit
valls aujourd'hui c'est exactement la
même chose qui est dit mais quand il dit
je suis d'accord
le parti socialiste est mort il y avait
deux gauches irréconciliables
il l'avait déjà dit et théorisé avant
valls un accroc avant macro lui avant de
maquereaux lui même et je m'accorde ans
après ils n'ont pas eu les mêmes les
mêmes itinéraires henin qui a eu
peut-être le courage de démissionner et
l'autre qui a pensé qu'il aurait il
serai plus fort en restant je pense que
c'est c'est ça mais au fond sur le faut
quand même les deux sont à peu près
d'accord non je suis inquiète plus
souriante l'autre non non mi longs et
bien sûr qu'ils ont des points d'accord
mais en même temps ils ont au niveau du
gouvernement quand ils étaient tous les
deux gouvernements ils n'étaient pas
d'accord sur tout ils se sont quand même
combattu et sont les maris si je voulais
c'est que ces histoires des ego et de
fonction une politique sans doute une
fonction rina maquis jouer quand même la
fidélité absolue au président de la
république qui était manuel valls et
l'autre qui si on est émancipée qui
était emmanuel macron l'a peut-être que
maintenant manuel valls se dit il aurait
probablement dû démissionner beaucoup
plus tôt même pour faire ça sa première
fois primé en une démission entre loivre
non mais c'est vrai que donc la sphère
valls ne vous choque pas je suis triste
pour lui parce que ça va passer devant
la commission des conflits
c'est joli nom de la commission des
conflits elle était déjà saisi depuis le
mois d'avril
oui du fait qu'il devait donner à mener
pas il soit pas prononcé pour un mot
grossesse double peine double peine mais
enfin presque interdit la double peine
voilà est-ce qu'il restera suffisamment
de monde pour siéger à cette commission
des conflits parce qu'on ne sait pas
c'est pas c'est parce que crée ce que
doit craindre le plus frais des départs
gros bol qu'on banalise dans tout le
monde connaît la droite c'est mignon et
la régate où la parole se lit période
nous sommes en train d'y en transition
face à 100 enfin bref jean baptiste
manuel valls ou non mais c'est vrai que
bon après avoir dit le parti sioniste
était mort donc c'est vrai que se
trouvait devant le cadavre pour entendre
que finalement on ne fait plus partie du
mort certaine position assez difficile
mais il est vrai qu'on est complètement
mais bon je te comprends mieux la
position du parti socialiste c'est vrai
que c'est un peu du côté du parti dans
marche il est totalement orphelin d'un
point de vue politique c'est vrai qu'il
est complètement sur la ligne emmanuel
macron donc bon le parti en marche a
pris sa décision et c'est vrai que
l'avenir politique des manuels valls est
complètement de manuel valls est
complètement incertain et
c'est donc deux ans trois ans il
représentait evry son lit et renuart
sans l'étiquette réduit et la peña
gravira on aurait dû mettre son cv
directement sur notre ordinateur et
peut-être que c'était une bonne idée
mais bon de toute façon sur le fond je
ne sais pas si c'est une bonne idée
d'avoir pour en marche d'avoir manuel je
pense très honnêtement que quand on a
accepté françois bayroux ont font
certains difficile si on se met à
tanguer notre avis votre avis soit
bayrou engagées ont permis l'élection de
les médias s'il n'est pas là c'est pas
sûr qu'ils soient en tête au premier
tour a nancy il a porté un sacré coup de
pouce je pense que vous avez été décisif
j'ai pas toujours se moquer de tout mais
aujourd'hui quand ils se présentent tout
seul il fait plus il fait plus rien
bayrou donc les faits si j'ai pour cent
non non pas juste combien de temps enfin
en tout cas à venir si on accepte bayrou
manuel valls allez renouveau de trucs à
vous parler de personnes nous parlons du
fond jean charest pour manuel valls il
n'y a pas plus de raisons pour anna côté
certain temps dans marche après les
élections oui juste un soleil voilé qui
peu de temps jusqu'où thé jus il fallait
qu'ils quittent juppé b hôpital
on pouvait le faire ils pouvaient
quitter le ps plutôt c'est un peu c'est
juste un peu la différence c'est qu'il y
en a un qui est allé plutôt parler de
jean lassalle encore bon je viens
justement puisqu'on en est dans cette
nouvelle façon peut-être de faire de la
politique alors on ne connaît pas encore
le nom du futur premier ministre
il ya deux noms qui circulent is vous
avez cité un nom j'ai cité un nom il ya
longtemps qu'il ya bien longtemps sylvie
goulard ziegler et dont je pense qu'elle
sera le briviste mais on parle aussi du
maire du havre qui serait proche de
juppé et edouard philippe
est-ce que nommé edward fini que
justement ça serait pas de la vie
politique c'est à dire faire pression
essayé de diviser la droite tout de
suite de d'enfoncer un coin dans une
droite qui est déjà divisé vieille ou
neuf c'est de la politique et je pense
que en effet l'intérêt de macron c'est
de ces deux terminé le travail de sape
sur sa droite sur sa gauche c'est déjà
fait mélenchon il ya bien aidé mais sur
sa droite
alors il ya quelques fissures un jeu qui
cache peut-être de véritables gouffres
on le saura dans on sera dans un mois
mais en revanche je formellement et
apparemment les républicains semblent
pour l'instant tenir le coup avec conte
sur le c'est donc sans doute des
manoeuvres des manoeuvres du couloir ils
tiennent le coup pour l'instant avec un
certain nombre de gens enfin on va faire
deux saisons mais comme comme bertrand
par exemple qui est vont essayer
probablement de se constituer un groupe
parlementaire autour d'eux et venir
appuyer le le gouvernement au pouvoir ou
le président de la république après
l'initiative terre neuve à partir tout
de suite du parti républicain mais mais
constituent un groupe qui est puis les
épéistes aussi enfin bon ça peut c'est
pour ça que est ce que j'ai vu parce que
c'est un peu la même chose que valls
si on n'accepte pas valser ce qu'il faut
faire de la politique on de sion tout de
suite de foncer ce pot dans la droite en
nommant un premier ministre qui vient en
effet du parti république
il vient bien évidemment du parti
républicain mais il fait pas partie du
top 10 des personnalités du parti
républicain se veut dire dans le grand
public pour l'instant personne ne
connaît le maire du havre à part les
gens du hamas à se dire c'est pas une
pose la question dans la rue jean
c'était moi dix personnalités politiques
de droite
personne ne citera son nom pour
l'instant donc c'est plutôt
intellectuellement enfin ça peut être
satisfaisant etc mais sympa ça me paraît
pas être un calcul politique
le vraiment fait pour diviser la droite
voilà il y avait des remarques à des
pointures plus fort mais à dire c'est un
choix politique satellisant intéressant
car leurs pagnes de oui oui mais
s'approche du plateau grammy mais c'est
pas une prise de guerre pendant
démentiel pour l'opinion publique
soyez premier ministre a écouté on sait
pas pourquoi elle a démissioné donc mais
oui il ya des manoeuvres dans cette
histoire plus interne au il était
consiste concurrencé par eric ciotti wii
qui prenait la main sur ses pas le parti
je crois qu'il veut reprendre à nouveau
la main pour moi ça c'est autre chose
mais justement sur les quelques
laboratoires philippe juste une chose
c'est que comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure ses îles
en marche c'est des gens de droite et
sont des gens de gauche qu'est ce qui
aurait de choquant d'avoir un premier
ministre que c'est choquant voilà donc
qui moi ça me choquerait pas les pacsés
chaud qu est-ce que c'est pas la
politique politicienne qui nuiraient qui
pourrait nuire à l'image de faire la
politique du nouveau nom sur ça fait
partie même si je sais pas depuis
combien c'est en ville que je suis bête
ça devient un excellent match entre
valls oui et ce que je veux dire
ça fait un député de plus le collimateur
du champ ce jour en soi et non non pas
pour dumiste n'ont qu'à me demandant de
le laisser le soutenir dans sa lutte au
sommet lands allemands c'est quelqu'un
qui n'est pas connue je sais pas depuis
combien de temps il est en politique et
dans philippe je n'ai aucune idée est un
mandat de dépôt
donc on est dans le renouvellement
quelqu'un qui est plutôt jeune
et qui c'est important y a plus une très
longtemps ya peu une de ses stars dont
on balance entre un homme de gauche ou
de droite mais bon en panne au choix
entre nombre de noirs et sylvie goulard
est une des plus tôt une centriste aux
façades
c'est une ancienne otage fireweed tu
exploses andra c'est vrai que bon il
incarne aussi le bilan de françois
hollande et que les français veulent
avant tout elle est allée à autre chose
et que ça devait normalement être la
droite et n'oublions pas que la droite a
été torpillé par rapport aux affaires de
françois fillon dont il ya encore une
inconnue sur le party les républicains
peut-être qu'il dit il c'est encore les
faveurs des français et puis les quelque
chose donc voilà c'est donc ça la gêne à
blanc tout cas on ne sait pas
d'habitation et je crois aussi que
manuel emmanuel macron a bien conscience
aussi à travers effectivement cette
règle des 50 % de personnes qui relèvent
de la société civile que ses chansons
relate fin soit assez faible de voir ces
candidats obtenir assurément donc la
circonscription qu'ils vont convoiter
parce qu'ils n'auront pas d'expérience
électorale ils sont complètement nouveau
alors on parle on ne connaît toujours
pas le nom de ses candidats donc c'est
demain c'est à dire un jeu des choses et
je pense qu'il a conscience qu'il
n'obtiendra pas une majorité absolue des
suffrages exprimés et que parallèlement
à hull
moi j'en suis aujourd'hui quasiment
enfin j'en suis papa quasiment convainc
puis assez convaincu la majorité je 180
il faut 289
289 et c'est vrai que les alors qu'on
peut avoir comme comme sondages
aujourd'hui donne un truc 240 250 et il
en manque un paquet il ya beaucoup de
candidats à droite qui laboure les
besoins depuis très longtemps qu'ils ont
les fans de lors de leurs concitoyens je
pense ça sera très difficile pour
d'obtenir cette majorité et je pense que
du coup par pas par machiavélisme et par
bon sens politique
il se dit qu'il faut absolument un
premier ministre de droite qui de
surcroît une expérience politique
à tout le moins parlementaire et je
pense que d'un point de vue du bon sens
politique le calcul est bon et le calcul
est bon aussi dans l'hypothèse où les
législatives donnant une majorité aux
républicains de conserver un premier
ministre qui va rester dans le temps
puisqu'il sera déjà de droite donc
passez législatives donc marié d'edouard
philippe vous pariez ne s'est pas du
tout parlé de un jeu paris moi je parie
rien barrier je ne sais pas message
d'annoncé sur les législatives où leurs
droits des malades parce que vous me
demandez si je parlais sur le
législatives qu'elle serait si on a la
majorité au oui moi je pense à être
plutôt edouard philippe lui la semaine
prochaine détruire l'émission dès que le
premier ministre nommé les blagues
magnétique pour les banques
justement jean baptiste vous disiez ben
c'est pas sûr du tout que une majorité
en marche
à l'assemblée nationale il ya une règle
de la vème république jusqu'à présent
avec
le quinquennat puisque les deux
élections sont concordantes
et même avec le septennat quand il y
avait une dissolution de l'assemblée
nationale c'est que les français donnent
une majorité au président qu'ils ont
élus est-ce que là encore on est dans
une situation c'est ce que vous avez à
venir un peu nouvelle par rapport à
cette règle profond qui s'est vérifié à
presque à chaque fois l'équipe non mais
justement il faut vraiment attendre
est ce que véritablement la campagne
qu'ils étaient menés par emmanuel macron
va être créé le l'effet d'entraînement
traditionnel donc lui permettant
d'obtenir une majorité à l'assemblée
nationale c'est pas du tout une règle
constitutionnelle
c'est un fait politique c'est un repas
sur site qui accouchent d'ailleurs du
mode de scrutin qui est le scrutin
majoritaire et qui permet donc
normalement de créer les conditions du
bipartisme mais là on comprend bien que
peut être comparé sur un nouveau but
partisme voilà donc il ya comme une
singularité lorsqu'on parle de
cohabitation quand on parle de
cohabitation on parle des trois exemples
précédents on a donc celle de 86 2 93
c'est à dire françois mitterrand ou à
chaque fois il était mis en minorité par
rapport des élections législatives qui
arrivait donc cinq ans après puisqu'il y
avait donc ce décalage entre le les
années l'effort puisqu'il a inventé le
septennat de deux ans qu'est ce qui est
intéressant dans ces deux cas et ce qui
est vrai aussi pour la troisième
cohabitation pour les deux ans seulement
c'est que le président la république élu
à elle le temps de dérouler son
programme présidentiel de les mettre en
oeuvre
voilà donc la cie parricide aventure oui
c'est une sorte d'échec est quand même
des majorités l'agencé a tout à fait le
même une sanction et c'est exactement
une sanction par rapport à la mise en
oeuvre du programme président aventure
emmanuel macron ne connaît pas une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale on
aurait pour la première fois un
président qui n'aura qui n'aurait pas
été pour le coup sanctionné pour un
programme qui n'est par définition
n'auraient pas encore mises en oeuvre
c'était assez singulier c'est pour ça
même quand on parle de cohabitation
oui mais d'un point de vue de la
légitime légitimité politique on a un
prénom la république qui a été élu par
le peuple français
de l'autre côté on à l'assemblée
nationale qui elle aussi un kart à poids
égal cette même légitimité
donc c'est assez singulier de voir que
on pourrait avoir cette hypothèse vous
pour le coup les français se
contredisent radicalement
évidemment le b le jeu des voix fait des
choses plus compliquées mais c'est ce
serait assez impressionnant et inédite
qu'est ce qu'on appelle une cohabitation
elle nécessiterait que un groupe de
droite ou au choix républicain où les
socialistes
et si à peu de choses et la majorité
absolue à l'assemblée
oui il faut pour l'instant aucune
projection ne semble-t-il une fin ne
donne cette hypothèse mais ça peut
arriver mais ça peut arriver
et puis comme emmanuel macron se pose à
la fois à droite et à gauche
ce que l'hypothèse de l'accusation est
aussi totalement possible puisque dans
ce cas là ça veut dire qu'il mettrait
plutôt un coup de barre à gauche mais
qui sera plutôt à droite et là pour le
coup je pense que on peut s'en faire de
risques trop fort dire que le premier
ministre sera de droite et que donc il
essaiera de créer les conditions pour
avoir finalement une majorité qui ne lui
soit pas trop défavorable mais je pense
qu'on pourra pas être dans quelque chose
d'assez manichéen avec il durera
cohabitation il n'aura pas cohabitation
oui c'est peut-être plus voilà où des
majorités des ou des banalités ça parce
que ce qui s'était passé un peu du temps
d'euros 4,8 où il n'y avait pas une
majorité absolue et où il fallait à
chaque fois négocier pour aller essayer
de chercher deux ou trois députés alors
c'était pas beaucoup mais enfin il
fallait quand même le faire graisser
entre 88 et 91 donc michel rocard
premier ministre guy carcassonne
conseiller à matignon qui étaient aux
mains à la manoeuvre s'est salué
aujourd'hui comme étant digne de 2,2 ce
qu'au fond la vème république a pu faire
être de pourrait être dans dans sa
version la plus
la plus démocratique lui républicaine
c'est à dire des majorités d'idées vous
l'avez dit il y avait peu de députés à
convaincre à chaque fois enfin il
fallait quand même y aller chercher les
voix aller chercher les centristes il
fallait discuter parlementer dans un
parlement ce qui n'est pas si saugrenue
que cela il ya une forme d'exemplarité
le petit handicap de votre préférée
sylvie goulard parce qu'elle n'a pas
d'expérience parlementaire nationale et
les parlements et jettent au parlement
européen mais c'est capté et de négocier
enfin les voilà des mots qui sont
parlement vers le monde s'était pas fait
l'expérience
ils seront bien à ce que vous disiez ce
que dit jean baptiste
après tout dans le programmes des
manuels mâcon macron il ya la volonté
d'introduire une part de proportionnelle
aux législatives ce qui rend plus
compliquée encore la constitution d'une
majorité uniforme donc on est bien dans
cette tendance là où on veut essayer de
trouver des majorités d'idées de
négociation et de voilà tout d'avoir des
majorités parfois j'ai ouïe très
variables non pour compléter lorsque 10
et stéphane michel rocard donc c'est
vrai a créé ces conditions de majorité
d'idées il essayait donc décroché son
téléphone mais il a aussi beaucoup
utilisé le 49 alinéa 3 d'avoir à 28
reprises et utilisé le plus et emmanuel
macron enfin en tout cas son premier
ministre n'a n'aura plus cette arme
puisque la constitution été révisé en
2008 et qu'on ne peut plus utiliser à
volonté le carreau l'alpha dînatoire ne
peut utiliser qu'une seule fois par soir
donc en faisant les variantes us
mais pardon oui donc il serait vraiment
obligé pour le coup donc d'obtenir de
créer des conditions de cette coalition
qu'ils soient qu'ils lui soient
favorables et ça sera vraiment je pense
une gageur et puis alors c'est
l'histoire la dose proportionnelle s'il
l'a mais s'il l'a prévoit elle ne vaudra
que pour les prochaines élections
législatives
oui la réduction d'un an mais mais mais
ces désaccords mais ça montre je dirais
une voie vers laquelle on voit les c'est
à dire en effet une représentation oui
tout à fait le plus vrai de vote des
français et en même temps une
constitution de majorités plus difficile
la fin et on peut faire une hypothèse je
me pose la question de savoir si cette
le fait de prévoir cette dose de
proportionnelle qui sera pas une
proportionnelle intégrale mais enfin
windows quand même ne lui donnerait pas
l'occasion de faire ce que jacques
chirac avait fait sur le conseil de jpc
de prononcer la dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale
il pourrait se dire si d'aventuré il
était en difficulté qui n'arrivait pas à
créer les conditions de cette coalition
de ce tueur bout de deux trois ans je
dissous l'assemblée nationale et puis
cela permettra de mettre en oeuvre la
promesse que j'avais fait une dose de
proportionnelle de pouvoir avoir une
représentation beaucoup plus fidèle des
différents partis politiques et donc
d'avoir un une arme une justification
pour prononcer cette dissolution et en
plus ce serait compliqué par un certain
nombre de députés qui pourraient pas se
représenter parce qu'ils auront cumulé
trois mandats dont il y en a énormément
qui sortirait plus la réduction du
nombre de parlementaires et donc ça
reconfigurer complètement le
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat oui
alors si pardon sans compter l'irruption
si j'en crois d'autres philosophe
préféré d'une majorité de députés
protestants six mois on va les
d'économie à une question qui est à la
limite du droit constitutionnel et de la
science politique c'est celle des
ordonnances voilà ça commence à faire
débat
il ya beaucoup de gens qui disent ah oui
les ordonnances et pas démocratiques à 0
est-ce qu'on confond pas un peu enfin
dans le dans le public les ordonnances
justement il 49 3 oui alors les
ordonnances et l esclave esca la
brutalité de l'ain elle est là de l'une
est la même que la totalité de notre
édile a supposé que les deux armes sera
brutal moi je considère pas que le 49e
lensois est antidémocratique je crois
que c'est pro démocratique puisque ça
donne l'occasion aux députés de se dire
bon bah écoutez on va jusqu'au bout la
gorge de construire et puis on se
représente dans les français c'est le
peuple qui tranche voilà donc il faut
pas inverser les choses parce qu'on
entend beaucoup le 49e mocratique mais
ça donne l'occasion au peuple de se
prononcer donc c'est une arme magnifique
et il correspond bien d'ailleurs à
l'idée que se faisait le général de
gaulle 2 de la constitution plus après
les députés prennent leurs
responsabilités ils prennent leurs
responsabilités ce qui n'est pas le cas
pour les ordonnances donc si on reprend
la ji vous aviez pris c'est moins brutal
dans la mesure où des ça parce que
bardot ça a été considéré comme brutal
dernièrement enfin quand manuel valls
lalala utilisé et si j'ai bien compris
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
emmanuel macron s'est présentée c'est de
se dire si on est obligé d'utiliser le
49-3 c'est que la démocratie marche mal
et c'est une des raisons afin qu'ils
nous poussent à se dire il faut changer
un peu le système mais bon faut la
restaurer tous les faits consacré paix
et pour les ordonnances
c'est une bonne pour moi c'est une bonne
technique s'est elle permet il faut pas
oublier que le parlement se prononce à
lac doré de l'habilitation verser
l'article 38 de la constitution qui
prévoit que le parlement habilite le
gouvernement à intervenir pour un
domaine qui auraient normalement de la
compétence du parlement
donc il en définit le champ les limites
une date qui est fixée le gouvernement
fait donc le travail du parlement il
intervient dans son dos
donc ils prévoient une ordonnance qui
qui va définir pour le coup je crois que
c'est pour le code du travail qui fait
lever l'air et dans un second temps et
le risque pour cela est assez majeur il
faut que le parlement ratifie la loi le
l'ordonance pardon mais pour que celle
ci puisse entrer en vigueur
donc le risque est grand c'est à dire
que cc cc oui ou non et si le
gouvernement présente une ordonnance qui
ne correspond pas une réforme du code du
travail qui ne correspondent pas aux
attentes du parlement est bien
l'objectif escompté ne sera pas atteint
puisque dans ce cas là ça va relancer la
machine législative donc le parlement
n'est pas du tout de déposséder de son
pouvoir il intervient pour un fixer les
limites au départ et pour approuver in
fine et il les négociations ne sont pas
exclues des ordonnances et verglacée va
très bien négocié avec les syndicats
pour savoir quels domaines justement ce
sont d'autres dans le domaine dans
lequel il vint à venir ses oubliettes
mais le faire des 10 des négociations
avec les partenaires sociaux mais dont
on entend beaucoup de voix daniel cohn
bendit de gens qui le soutiennent génère
un évènement macro qui est ce que là
aussi à part risque parce que c'est
quand même ça c'est de l'impuissance du
pouvoir qui est et qui a été sanctionné
si en effet on va plus aux négociations
dans le parlement si on ne fait pas les
ordonnances la ban de ne rien faire
comme prophète jean baptiste a raison 49
alinéa 3 c'était là au cours des
derniers la dernière année c'était
vraiment le la dictature et puis les
ordonnances ça suffit revenons un peu à
la raison revenons au texte revenant la
légitimité du texte qui envisagent tous
ces outils qui ce qui a été approuvé
quand même par le parlent par le peuple
dans son pouvoir constituant ce n'est
pas rien
donc voilà enfin jeu
je arrêtons de nous agiter sur des
cheveux qui n'en valent pas la peine
puisqu'ils sont pas content il va
dégainer l'article 16 et puis c'est tout
non mais c'est vrai nom mais on confond
un peu tout ça pour ça l'idée voilà non
mais villa serait sympa explique ces
gens venaient dans les facultés de droit
assister aux cours de gym et de café de
la danse à votre âge je dire brutale
parce que c'est comme ça que ça effet
interprétée par nombre de députés et par
benoît hamon notamment dans sa compagne
enfin voilà et un certain nombre de deux
frondeurs socialiste pour ses fins il
n'était pas loin de cela ni de déposer
une motion de censure servait plus beaux
fabo n'ont pas fait peut-être les deux
stades de cinq minutes alors un petit
mot quand même du front national parce
que c'est pas inintéressant ce qui se
passe alors il y avait beaucoup de gens
qui disaient voilà c'est la fin de
marine le pen ça va être marrant je
prenne le pen qui va la remplacer
c'est rapide c'est raté pour l'instant
râteau l'instant et corps partout
son départ ressemble fort à une mise en
réserve au mieux pour mieux revenir bien
sûr vous croyez à élever sa fille de
trois ans et bien oui je crois or
passion cette élection dans peut-être
qu'elle reviendra après trois ans d r d
et parce qu'il ya quand même des risques
pour marine le pen ne serait pas au jury
qu'elle a bien sûr de dub inéligibilité
dont est bien sûr enfin ces souris c'est
que maintenant elle va elle a dit
qu'elle allait répondre à la justice
mais après les élections donc on va voir
si elle va répondre à la justice y avoir
une levée de la levée de son immunité
parlementaire européen
après faut voir si elle va être élu ou
pas député législatives mais la justice
va l'a convoqué il est possible qu'elle
soit mise en examen et ça va dérouler et
elle sera dans les cinq ans à venir en
tout cas avant les prochaines élections
je ne sais pas si elle sera condamné ou
pas mais si elle est condamnée elle sera
condamnée à une peine d'inéligibilité
donc pour l 2022 c'est a priori si elle
est condamnée s'étaient fixés les coves
évêché condamné à une année de gpt été
aussi bas c'est à dire que comme elle va
prêtre va pas être jugés avant compte
tenu de la rapidité de la justice en
france a pas de juge avant trois quatre
ans de deux ans
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que il faut 4 aux
recherches mais lequel
on ne manquera pas je pense que fin
philippe au site otegi plus à réaliser
non mais ça c'est un autre monde 10
c'est la ligne filet pour regretter
qu'elle les sanctionner enfin oui
sanctionné faut pas exagérer non plus
les 11 millions de gens qui ont voté
pour cette ligne
les premiers colons des années donné
marine le pen en tête au premier tour et
donné plus de 40 pour son deuxième tour
donc voilà c'est relatif aux maisons
d'enfants par rapport à l' ambitieux qui
pouvait la leur oui je pense que ce qui
est condamné à vous avez raison il ya 11
millions de personnes qui ont voté pour
marine le pen
mais ce qu'il a condamné m c'est la
façon dont elle s'est tenue pendant le
débat et ça je pense que ça elle va le
porter longtemps tout à fait c'est
pourtant je pense qu'elle a prouvé
pendant le débat qu'elle n'avait pas la
stature d'une femme d'état d'un homme
d'état c'est assez clair et n'est donc
les gens se sont dit on peut pas c'est
un concert cette femme qui
représenterait la france n'importe où
afin que jean nationale n'est pas
fréquentable certes chose qu'elle a
essayé de faire c'est des années mais je
pense que c'est plus celle que le
le débat c'est son échec à rennes un
échec personnel c'est pas l'échec de la
ligne du front national avec un dvd mais
avec un débat pareil avec une une telle
ignominie intel de ce rictus permanence
à l'iss est passé de 6 annoncée c'est
parce qu'il s'est planté
et franchement la preuve que que la
ligne est pas si nul que ça pour les
gens qui l'apprécient c'est quand même
11 millions de gens en dépit de ceux de
ce débat catastrophique donc c'est
vraiment elle qui mise en couvrir les
voix de gauche puisque c'était ça la
ligne et aux philippines et droite et de
gauche sont pas connus très facilement
au front national au deuxième tour et il
y a une tendance notre tendance qui qui
peut s'entendre qui dira non plus à
droite et peut-être faisant alliance
avec une partie de la droite qui est
prête à regarder ça enfin plus plus à
droite c'est décide de jean marie le pen
ya face à chirac cessé d'aider des gens
vraiment d'extrême droite en france
comptera maintenant les gens voudraient
nous faire croire
la france n'est pas peuplé de fasciste
et de et de gens qui n'ont qu'une envie
c'est de mettre tout le monde dehors
c'est pas vrai c'est quand même beaucoup
plus sur les 11 millions de gens
énormément de jeu de mécontents parce
que j'ai des macros tout à fait jean
colère donc arrêtons de penser toujours
que ce que c'est il faut aller à droite
tout pour le front national
non je pense que la ligne de filippo
elle est sûrement vous êtes pour est
intelligente et visiblement pour vaincre
enfin moi ne me convainc pas mais mais
elle a convaincu aux unions gens donc
c'est très bien
c'était sur cette parole maintenant
méritent beaucoup joué le nom de ce
philosophe
merci mon sang remercie beaucoup mais
jean baptiste des claques et alors je
vous donne cette phrase pour que vous
avez méditer l'anomalie dollar entre
deux civilisations va disparaître peu à
peu c'est dans la logique des choses
même si vous me dites que vous êtes
insoumis très bien mais à pieters le
thermique au revoir
[Musique]